[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
now
all we need are some death metal lyrics
[Laughter]
guys welcome back once again to the
corridor cast
it's good to be back gentlemen it's been
really good to be here
brad's got a fresh beer you're making me
want to grab one too but it's all the
way over there
all the way over there it's all the way
over there
uh today we have four special guests so
i guess can i include myself as a
special guest
does that count absolutely okay not
oh all right well we have three special
guests we've got
obviously the most the most special
laugh the best laugh of them all
clinton jones everybody what's up y'all
man the myth the legend and of course
mr matt karens how you doing buddy oh
doing great
doing great uh so um
who's got a beer here it's just you red
is it just me
dang i mean should i
i got a spin drift it's the best i can
do but
you boys give me one second okay yeah
let me get some wine i'm gonna get some
wine
all right do it i love that that's just
become a thing on this podcast
we just drink on it i mean it's kind of
you know it gives it that relaxing like
social
absolutely experience which i think is
more enjoyable what we need to do is
drink a beer first
and then record the podcast you devil
um no what we need to do is down 10
beers each and then we record the
podcast
people would love that little tropic
thunder going on right now
we got all these beers you guys have
served
we drink some hipster beers dude
it's the only way to live jake that that
freaking pretentious beer
it's not that lone star texas stuff oh
man
uh okay so explain to me what you guys
have here
red what do you got i have a hazy double
ipa
from dig my earth
yeah dig that earth it's got stickers
instead of an actual label
what is that what is that on the front
actually it's a
it's a fox that has been like split open
and to reveal the inside there's
probably an image online that's better
than like my webcam focusing up close
but
yeah wow i don't want to be the guy that
goes um
actually uh but um actually
it's the brewery is brewery west oh is
it
yeah you're right you're right yeah yeah
that's okay so dig my earth is the name
of the beer
yes that's right what do you got matt
i got a uh it's called a tropic thunder
bing bang boom
it's a berliner wise uh berliner with uh
with
strawberry pineapple papaya and mango
hey it's a florida thing actually hidden
springs
it sounds like the the mango sounds like
it's got florida vibes
yeah people yeah bringing me right back
to that that beautiful
weird state yeah it's so weird you guys
follow
do you guys ever follow florida man
headlines oh yeah
yes yeah i have to live that i had to
live that every day of my life so
yeah you know you just can't make it up
no like i mean the most popular one of
course is the the face eater in miami
yeah on the bath salts that that made
like the world
yeah yeah florida man turns into zombie
yeah yeah the whole the whole country
thought we were in a zombie apocalypse
because of that man yeah
no it's just a man attempting it's just
a florida man attempting to smoke bath
salts
that's no big deal no big deal
oh florida ah wow
so um guys uh i wanted to talk
hurry ho ho i poured two things i
because i realized hey you all got your
fancy drinks i poured myself
right so moving on we got uh
you know what that's not fancy enough so
i poured myself some lagavulin 16.
oh that is my dad's favorite scotch
this is casey's this is casey's favorite
i didn't know nothing about that that's
right that's right casey is a fan of
logan villain
until yeah it's uh until
i guess yeah casey and kevin and i was
like
it all just tastes horrible and this is
the least horrible tasting one
and you know the more drinky one the
better it gets
yes indeed my parents visited the actual
distillery in scotland
a few years back
uh cheers everybody cheers cheers
are you and jake water
i'm on that ice water with you know they
make those uh like
added flavor eyes like minerals and
stuff
you know you can add like b12 and all
that stuff so
i got some of that going usually i have
a beer but but
you know i had a few beers yesterday so
i'm kind of
chilling not having a beer right now
which is good to do
in between beers yeah yeah in between
yeah
you gotta stagger it yeah yeah yeah i
barely drank anything yesterday i only
had like a couple dozen beers so today
i'm gonna
ramp it up a little for sure barely
drake yeah
yeah um cool guys so
uh so over the weekend who's cat is
meowing by the way
it's mine she'll be done in a second
leave
she's her alone she's so elderly that
like her hips if when she sits down
she like really else yeah really yeah
she's an old cat oh my god
um how long have you had that cat
since i was 10 years old
really since then yeah yeah i've had
that dude that's
awesome yeah how do you feel a little uh
i am 26. so dang man that's an old cat
do that that's awesome that means you
that cat is
18 years old nailed it that's why
that's why ren is the math guy yeah
that's why he does all those mathy
videos
yeah because he's able to
subtract 10 from 26 and get the right
answer
every time totally i'm unique in that
way
um so we put out a video over the
weekend
guys two videos one big one but one big
one
so well even then of course the writing
process before that but that's six
months in the making
and uh there was a huge gap in time
where that project wasn't worked on at
all though it's not like we worked on it
non-stop since march
it was tinkered with it was like it was
yeah it was worked on
really hard when we filmed it it was
super difficult like i mean it's not
super difficult but filming is always
difficult when like
you're you're filming for a full day and
it's a whole thing and there's a bunch
of people
and then especially oh yeah there's day
two and then oh yeah there's like
there's oh yeah there's day three and
then there's pick up day and then pick
up day two
and then like it all comes into the edit
and it's just like
oh okay um well for context on when that
happened
you guys were in san antonio san antonio
uh texas you guys were in texas filming
that video
at the same time that i was on the roof
battling jan with my nerf drone
the same time that coronavirus started
to become a thing because i remember
we dude it's so funny me and dean wore
masks
in the in the uh airport and jake was
like what are y'all wearing masks for
you guys look ridiculous i was like yo
yo yo yo
just in case you never know what's gonna
happen that's right yeah
we get there and yeah like it's it's
chill you know we get there as chill
and then we're hearing news and
apparently some lady who had it she like
went to the
went to the mall she was released from
the from like the doctors or whatever
like yeah you have it and then she like
went to the mall and then they shut them
all down
and then two days later we're coming
back we got our masks and everything
and then i think we all had masks at
that point and i just remember like dean
was telling me we were taking the like
tram back to like the uber
parking lot and dean was sitting with
this one lady
and you know they're talking for a
little bit about
she's asking him questions about his
bone phones and then she like he's like
all right cool cool he puts his bone
phones on
she gets on the phone she's like yeah
these people are just so stupid and
ridiculous with their masks
and dean dean was like like i mean
i could hear you like it was really
weird it was really weird
and we were just like i will still
remember that woman um
where were you on a bus no yeah we were
we were on like one of the trams taking
you to
from lax to the uber parking lot so
it was like and she was talking about
you right in front of you to her like
yeah like like they couldn't like we
couldn't hear her or something i don't
know
what was going on maybe she just assumed
that the bone phones meant you can't use
your ears even though that's
the primary purpose of them yeah i think
so
well it was funny yeah yeah that's
ridiculous
in history that's where it was that's
where we were that was like the same
week that like
south by southwest was basically getting
shut down like one sponsor at a time
until the whole event was like all right
we're good and
nba cancelled at the same time it was
like everything happened within a week
of us like even us being like all right
hey we filmed this drone video and then
like everyone got back and then like
literally three days later it's like
okay we're all working from home now the
whole world is
yeah dude and i remember before that we
were so ignorant
we did not know what was about to happen
yeah and the crazy thing is that the
coronavirus was like a thing
for the previous five weeks of that like
it was you know
january i think 23rd or something like
that that like the first case in the us
and then all of february it was a thing
it just wasn't like a commonly
understood or known thing and of course
now everyone knows it
well how can you you know how can you
really until like
yeah people it's like it is
unprecedented
well it is it absolutely is and in the
day-to-day
routine of life you know people are
dying from everything every day
and there's there's there's tragedy
everywhere you go
and like people have enough of a time
just
you know it's it's enough of a a factor
in your life to just
focus on what you have in front of you
the things you have to do that day the
things you're trying to do with yourself
you know like everything that
goes into like trying to live a healthy
and productive lifestyle and and then
you know you're you're focused on the
news you're paying attention to things
that are happening in the world as much
as any other person
but it's not unfortunately this is the
way that it is it's not until like
it's like wait how many people have died
from this oh that's kind of a lot
oh that's that death rate's pretty high
um
you know and then you start to do the
math and then it's like oh and then
you know p but how how else do you get
out the information to people in like a
way that
actually is relevant to them unless it's
unless it's like to say
hey this thing that's got this
so far we don't know much about it other
than like hey it's it's really easily
contractible
it's got a pretty high death rate and uh
you know it's
it's it's gonna be around how do you get
people to pay attention to that before
that happens
it's like oh that's just a bunch of
other countries managed to do it
yeah yeah sort of sort of
i i just think it's crazy it's crazy to
me that people still
now are that woman on sitting next to
dean on the plane that was hating on him
did you guys see the whole freaking like
uh anti-mask
event rally that happened i think
yesterday the day before
the cough festival everyone just
coughing on each other yeah
wait did that literally happen yeah i
saw a video
of it i mean go i'll go for it i guess
but like
like that's just dumb what are you doing
yeah my favorite was the one woman who
was like
you know what you know who likes masks
pedophiles
no no no not pedophiles uh
uh sexual assaulters or something like
that it was
like what yeah sexual oh yeah okay
there's just a lot of excuses people
make as to
why that it's like a hindrance or it's
just like
you know i mean it's there's a pretty
there's a pretty like easy
you know common reasonable rational
thing
it's like look uh we know that this
spreads to people when they get in close
contact with one another so
generally in the interest of uh you know
maintaining this when you're out in
public or when you're out around people
that you don't
know that you aren't around you know
when you're in a gas station what have
you
yeah wear this that way you'll be less
likely to spread it or contract it
it's like it's not that not that big of
a deal
um and uh you know it's it's too bad
that it's become such a
uh like a somehow politicized issue
um it's pretty reasonable thing to ask
of people to say like hey this is a
problem
we're doing our best to identify it in
the meantime
everyone please try to do this when
you're out in public
so it's so easy to it's so easy to throw
out labels like you know calling people
sheep and stuff right
and so it just like it separates you
from them and it just it makes you go
like oh
well you know i'm not going to follow
these rules because these people are
idiots
you know and they're following rules
that don't make any sense
so but there's no there's no like merit
behind it there's no
science behind it just do it because the
other people are sheep
you know scare them yeah no totally
there is there is a little bit of that
like hipster logic to it like yeah anti
you just do it to be anti because it
makes you different
anti-establishment yeah yeah it's funny
how we got on this
whole tangent because we're talking
about how tactical reloads was born
in the same time period as all of the
lockdown
beginning yeah we filmed that right when
lockdown basically happened for everyone
so and so that's funny because we've
been since the birth of this we haven't
even said the name of it yet
we talked we said yeah i said this
project we went on
and i was good on you right i was gonna
say tactical but so for those of you who
have been listening for the last 10
minutes
don't know what project we're talking
about it's tactical three loads
third reload yeah we we went out uh
march and then you're right we came back
and uh pretty much right after that
there was the hard lockdowns and then
um you know now now kind of things are
beginning to
open up a bit you know we had the we had
the verizon cases and
we we're starting to work out of the
studio for a while yeah
pretty much all of june we had migrated
back to the studio but then it was like
it got to a point where it was uh
morally questionable
that we were there even if we were all
taking our own safety precautions and
getting tested regularly and all that
stuff is still just like
we probably should work from home again
to set a good example
at the very least yeah and like case
number fortunately case numbers
i don't mean just yeah this is going to
sound a little weird but case
fortunately case numbers got high but
death rates didn't
get proportionately the same high
you know like they didn't go up as much
as in proportion to cases which means
that the death rate went down
and so you know these are good things
overall i mean
a lot of people are still dying every
day but oh yeah no
listen yeah i'm not trying to make light
of it um you know there's about 200 000
people that have
died from this thing that's a lot of
people but um
i'm just saying like you know the more
we know about it the more we know about
like how to deal with it i feel like
everyone
yeah we had we had football finally this
weekend too
yeah and uh you know like at the texas
uh
the texas versus utep game they had 25
capacity in the stands which was awesome
to see for the first time and
like well since since march 14th
basically
yeah uh that that or crowd noise which
is always yeah
and the cardboard the cardboard people
are my favorite i love those little
cutouts they're so funny
we should do that for a video like
piping piping laughs or something
yeah yeah yeah yeah like like a live
studio audience but everyone's a
cardboard cutout
like home alone home alone for comedians
yeah that's like rocket league there's
just like these little like
balls in the stands oh yeah yeah so
tactical am i right
yes so technical yeah so let's talk
about the journey of this so
we got part of it and then
man then uh when when was the edit
done clint cause you know we went from
march well define
done three weeks ago one week ago okay
this is good context for people because
like i've got i've seen a lot of
comments of people when we talk in more
detail about how we work on things
people being like hey it's nice to know
that you guys go through these same
problems
when you're creating things as young
people so i think a better question is
when was the first rough edit
finished the first like timeline of
the first export where you're like all
right here's a rough thing this is
tactical three loads it kind of sucks
right now but here it is
um i don't know because that yeah i
guess that would be me but it's also
like clint you had it mostly like
assembled in a ruff
there were just like a couple of scenes
that weren't in there and like those
those intro scenes
um yeah so yeah i guess i did those and
then i did like a
a full pass on the whole thing um and
then
that brought us to uh the next step
cause then we
of course we also had a pickup day which
was months after
the fact where we had to get extra shots
for the video and then that had to get
edited in
and none of this is taking into account
visual effects or sound design
so basically it was like we came back
dumped all the footage
and this was the first project no this
was the second project i was using
davinci in
so nico really really likes davinci
and he wanted us to try it out and this
was for ghost hunters i think was the
first thing i tried it out on
and at this point i have uninstalled
premiere from my computer
so really i'm in i'm all in yeah it's
great
yeah yeah it's awesome um i was so
like torn i was so torn because i was
like
no i'm not just gonna do it because it's
convenient for you nico
screw that like i'm gonna do what's
convenient for me and
and i was like but but i'll give it a
shot
if that's what you're asking i'll give
it a shot so i made like a big list of
like pros and cons
between premiere and davinci and like
reset all my hotkeys
and ended up really liking it so um
what's your list of pros and cons can we
talk about that
um off the top of my head what i like
about davinci the ui
looks it looks nice but you cannot move
the windows around however you want like
you can in premiere which is yeah that's
that's a bummer
it is a bummer i got used to it you can
move it around a little bit like i
i worked it as much as i could work it
to get it to a place where i liked it
um the having two monitors it has like a
dual dual monitor view is nice
full screen timeline so your timeline is
large that's good
um it syncs sound really easily um
it obviously has the amazing color
ability
um it has fusion built in which i have
not messed with yet
um but um yeah no it does things that i
really like that are just like
really it just feels updated you know
adobe hasn't updated in so long
yeah and this is rt it's not true the
power of rtx
even premiere got a big upgrade earlier
this year did it really
yeah i mean premiere gets an upgrade
once or twice a year every year
i just feel like the the final straw for
me man was like i was
editing the oh i forgot i was trying to
no i was coloring one of the black rifle
videos the mortar team one i think
and i tried creating a folder
just creating a folder in premiere and
it wouldn't let me it just i was like
this is so dumb
wait wait because you need to create a
bin in premiere not a folder
well that's yeah that's what i mean i
was creating a bin and it like
actually
it wouldn't let me rename it and it was
like that's weird okay that sounds like
that that shouldn't happen that
shouldn't be the case i hear somebody
hear that as a frustration though that's
like
like what the hell but any anyway back
to
yeah there's junk with both programs
though for sure but like
you know 100 premiere premiere has a lot
of ridiculous jank that's just
extremely frustrating i do i do agree
with that like
especially with adobe products it's like
they're it works really well most of the
time but every now and then there's some
like weird
glitch that doesn't really like stop
your progress as much just be really
annoying like why
why is this here why is this a thing
okay one question i have clint
yeah and this is respective to the
mortar team project
now uh whenever we when you gave me back
that colorized footage
and i put it back into davinci
the edit ran super
that might be because of the vfx files
though the vfx exports are like
crunch up your edit yeah it's probably
the
the footage within your timeline
especially our like high
uh bitrate uh high uh bit depth
video files that we usually export all
our effects renders in
can we the mxf's though are they they go
smooth they're smooth
it might be a little this might be a
little inside baseball for people
listening but because is it possible to
do like
vfx proxies that aren't as high bit rate
so that they don't
tactical yeah we did that on tactical
but the mxf's we were exporting mxfs as
finals and those actually ran smooth
when i was going through everything
totally
nico wants all of us to use mxfs but we
also haven't figured out a way to export
msx
mxfs from premiere or after effects
i gave you i gave you the perfect way to
do it
we figured this out we don't have to
like pre-load anything or like build
drugs
it's totally it's so easy to just send
it to uh
to media encoder i hate that it's super
easy to do dude
it's super easy i'm sure there's a way
to perfect okay so listen
after effects davinci i was not wrong
there people are wondering this as well
you have to go to adobe media encoder
which is a different program
control m control m yeah it's like one
extra
m sketch shift m i can't do it
uh listen here's my big question about
about da vinci though
because whenever you colorize in
premiere i'm not talking about effect
shots now i'm talking about luts
and like colorizing footage anytime you
put a lot on top of a premiere timeline
it's just chug chug chug chug chug city
yeah yeah
off right yeah but so do you have the
same problem in da vinci if you
colorize and then go back the thing
about davinci is that it is built
for luts it is built for color this is
great the assumption is that
my assumption is that it is that it
wouldn't cause chugging
but it doesn't it doesn't okay so that's
good because
yeah there's still a couple things that
i found a little wonky about it but
when i edited mortar team in it but
i mean yeah no there's a wonk with uh
with everything and
da vinci's crashed on me out of the blue
for sure like
yeah um but yeah i'm enjoying like
i think just as an artist i like
learning new things as much as possible
even if at first i'm like you know
i know that it'll just help me grow my
value so yeah you know
i i would just be a better person a
better creator if i know more things and
da vinci's free like that is actually a
big deal
that is a big factor yeah well it's free
a version of it but if you want the like
studio version it's
that's not free it's like barely
different though it is it's it's
it's just got a few key pro features
that come with the studio version that
the free version doesn't have
and that is always changing like back in
the day you couldn't do 4k exports out
of the free version but i think now you
can
oh they've added more features to the
free version over time not less
yeah oh that's surprising you'd think
it'd be the opposite you'd think it'd be
like let's make it free
get as many people to adopt it as
possible and then we'll remove features
slowly just remove features i don't know
well that's
that's what every tech and telecom and
digital company does from shady business
okay okay can we can i go on a tangent
here can i go
please that's what these podcasts are
for okay
relevant to this uh you basically can't
get a broadcast signal anymore
what does that mean what do what exactly
like i talked about analog
yes well so analog a few years ago
switched over to digital
and it was longer than a few it was like
it was like 10 or 11 years ago
yeah it's like 10 or i guess i'm getting
old man i
i don't know um so no i remember i
remember the transition yeah
yeah so they you had to you know if you
wanted to if you wanted a free
broadcast signal to just take this back
first to one step
you have eight you have the big
u.s based broadcast companies and other
countries have these two but they have a
channel like nbc abc
cbs fox those all do terrestrial
broadcasts
that if you capture their signal which
is rebroadcasted in your area
you can watch those channels for free
right obviously yeah
just like terrestrial radio sure yeah
just like fm radio
now you used to be able to capture those
with
the bunny ear antennas but then they
went digital
and so then they started broadcasting a
digital signal
and so then you needed to buy a digital
antenna to connect it to your tv to
capture those same signals now you can
still do that
with most older tvs but with new tvs
maybe i'm wrong about this but i just
got a sony bravia tv
and i plugged in my digital antenna to
get my
broadcast signal so that i could watch
uh like an nbc football game
and it wouldn't can it would it would
run
the tune on it to like search for the
for the signal
but it would do it would do it from the
from the tv
not from the adapted signal not from the
extender that i was attaching to this oh
so it wasn't even
it didn't even know it had an antenna
attached to it didn't even know it had
an antenna attached to it
and and the built-in one is like
completely garbage
because it's this janky built-in signal
that's only
you know it's only extending so far and
so you're not so i got literally i got
three channels
that was all versions of the same
channel you know it was like 29.1
29.2 29.3 and none of them worked
and so this is a problem i've never
dealt with
yeah i've never heard of this i'm deep
into the weeds on this but hear me out
there you are
okay so when digital antennas came when
digital tennis came out
the whole the whole gripe was like
they're taking away free terrestrial
broadcast
guys get your guns you know and everyone
was like
look no we're not taking away free
terrestrial broadcast it's all going to
be fine
okay we'll even give you a government
subsidy to go out and buy
a digital receiver remember that you
could go out and
yeah actually website yeah you're able
to get cheap receivers
yeah and you if you just put in your
address and your name they'd send you
one
and now now they didn't what they didn't
think of
is that now the tvs themselves are set
up in such a way
that that like they're not going to be
more accessible to that technology going
forward they're going to be
less accessible to make it more
accessible to apps and
smart tvs and things like that which
makes sense from a product side
and from a consumer side but like it's
driven by who uses it
it's exactly it's driven by who uses it
now
there goes but terrestrial broadcast
effectively something that used to be
free
is now something that people pay for all
the time
even though technically it's still free
yeah
that's kind of like am radio though
isn't it or even maybe even fm
listen to sports on am radio people
still listen to am radio
sure and i i imagine someone my car
doesn't even have an am radio okay see
okay this is a great point sure you
haven't
have fm radio you're not driving an
iphone dude really
no and i i i kind of totally forgotten
this until we did the arkovit testing
for the first time a couple months ago
whereas the drive-through uh testing
thing at dodger stadium
and they have these big signs oh if you
want to watch this broadcast tune to
this am channel
and i was like i can't
[Laughter]
so it's not a weird thing like i totally
get like why that would
why that would happen right they're not
focused on
trying to make sure that you get great
am am radio
in your tesla because that's not the
purpose of the vehicle
but like i get netflix yes
my the thing that the thing that i'm
getting at more to my point is my point
is like it's it's a shame to lose
things that are free and that are
available to people
that are available across
wherever you come from and who however
much money you have and like all of that
stuff
because we're forgetting about them
we're not translating them
through to modern technology like why
aren't we translating
am radio through to modern technology so
that people can receive it with their
phones
for free yeah because they require big
antennas
yeah but they should be able to digitize
them and send them
through well we're still talking about
radio waves and radio waves
uh attenuate to very specific like
antennas
so you can't just like i mean i don't
know you can maybe design an antenna
that's really really tiny that'll pick
up an am
thing and and perhaps people have
already done that a lot i don't know i'm
just saying
you can digitize the signals and resend
them what like just over the airplane
over the internet um i think it comes
down to demand who wants that
not enough people 100 100 and that's
that's
that's that's totally the reason i'm
upset that i still can't use
floppy drives on my chromebook they're
flapping trash
i think you're missing my point maybe my
point
but okay but let me ask you this though
so if it's if
if that's the whole thing is like you
know there
because technology is changing we don't
have this any access to this anymore
yeah um what is the benefit of having
access to it for anybody
well like for example you you if you
translated it
across across technology
then you could continue to have things
that like information
that is i think what i'm what i'm
getting at is free information to the
public is a good thing
okay so if you can easily translate free
information to the public you benefit
people's lives without having to have
them be able to afford it
that's what i'm getting at yeah okay so
i think i understand so it's not so much
that like the advancement of technology
is making am and
all that stuff like obsolete which it is
it's the idea of that being like
this public utility yes yeah
exactly yeah that is kind of going away
simply because it's not being migrated
along with the other technology
yeah well maybe it's in the library you
know you got to just go to the
is for library emergency broadcast you
have to get
into the library check in every day
i don't know i i have there's a small
side of me that like thinks it would be
fun to like do something like that with
the site eventually where like we
somehow offer
not not that it would be like radio but
you you podcasts are now available on am
radio
to all you like digital.com subscribers
like you know you have programs where
it's like if you just listen to am
800 or whatever i don't know what
channel it is but like if you just
listen to an am
they'll play stuff for you you know
and so it'll give you like news and
it'll give you like you know some sort
of like
research research like journalism piece
you know and it'll give you like x
y and z it'd be nice to have something
like that like that's available
easily available on the internet right
now everything is
everything is everything's chosen by the
consumer
now and so just giving a little bit of
like the
hey since because you liked this here's
a here's a stream of this type of
information that you might find
enjoyable now what about like npr
national public radio yeah that's ra
that's radio still
you know that's the same thing i'm
saying so
so there is like a live am fm radio app
but that still means you need an app and
you still need technology
that costs money and that's basically
your point more people are going to have
that
technology than yeah the old technology
you still needed to buy a radio
yeah in order to get a radio signal so
yeah i'm not saying we should just so
we're clear
okay i'm not saying we should go back to
radios
just saying it'd be nice to translate
some of the free information that we got
into the modern age via today's
technology
it's understandable i don't know where
this started well i mean think about it
i mean
like the essence of that idea
the essence of all that free information
though is now like the epitome of
youtube youtube is
like the home of the world's best free
information for like
it's true and if you do click on a
youtube video it will auto play you
other videos that are related to that
information that's great you are still
at the whim of
an algorithm yeah feedback loops and all
that stuff
yeah we do need to be careful of those
those can be
dangerous dangerous feedback loop
algorithms kids
getting in your brain waves i mean
that's what i love about my spotify is
like it
bases playlists off of things that i
enjoy
and recommends me news like i really
think that's a great feature that they
have there
i dude for the longest time i had
downloaded
i have bought all my music downloaded
all my music put it on my iphone
and i because i like the idea of having
my music no matter where
i am like i don't have to log into any
crap
or like have any wi-fi like that's just
dumb so i want to have my
my music wherever i go if i'm camping
wherever but
i was like yeah fine i'll just fine i'll
get spotify i even got
it and then deleted it and i was like no
i didn't i don't like this and i came
back
eventually and was like oh yeah spotify
is pretty much the best
and like you can download your songs and
stuff but and and
yeah you can still literally store your
songs on spotify yeah that's the biggest
thing is like um
i didn't really discover any new music
until i got back on spotify
until then it was just like word of
mouth like oh you're into this you
should check out these guys but
you know because of spotify and the way
it
you know recommends cool stuff to me i'm
able to kind of grow my musical palette
just a little bit
it's like having a really good friend
that's like way too into music
constantly recommending you songs yeah
like and send me your links like
and send your likes every day into your
pocket
hey hey i heard you might like this
[Laughter]
dude stop emailing me are you stalking
me literally
like and then you listen to it you're
like yeah actually that's pretty good
okay this guy's good okay
yeah yeah man so
i don't know how we diverged off of
tactical from into the hole
you wanted to do a rant about a.m radio
yeah
you did that you were talking about
that's right yes yeah so um
so as it was we were talking about edits
changing and and uh new versions of
edits i believe
yeah and i think just structurally let's
just go down the pipeline maybe of how
how yeah we went from edit to the finals
that you see on youtube
right yes let's do it that's so cool yes
basically yeah the footage came in i
pieced together some stuff
it was missing reshoots basically i
pieced together temp music right that
went to matt because i was working on
um on uh
dominoes we were doing dominoes so yeah
oh boy i remember that one
yeah you saved my life dude i was in the
weeds for that on like for weeks
and i was like i was in bed and it was
like 12
30 in the morning am and and we're like
this is the night before the upload and
i get a text from clint cause we've been
working all the way up until midnight i
finally got into bed jenna's already the
whole week
the whole week the whole week every
night was like to midnight it was hard
and i get this text from you being like
oh no
and you would you texted me a photo of
like this hole
in the roto brushing that i had done i'm
just like like my head was missing
for like a few frames on the roto and
you're like oh
don't worry about dory i was like i
threw off my covers
i got up but i went back to my computer
and i like finished the shot i fixed it
we sent it back
dude you were such a hero that week like
i was like everyone's abandoned me
everyone's like off doing their thing
like i need help
and rand was like i got you and like
dude you stepped up you stepped down
you're like you're in this weeds
like filled water trench and and you're
looking around you're like guys guys yes
all of a sudden red just pops up through
the water
like decked out yeah it's it's like a
military advertisement he like reaches
his hand
[Laughter]
it was that dude so the worst part about
it though was that like i had put so
much effort into making sure all of my
rotoscopes were like
good and polished and whatnot and then
there was
one moment where i didn't like rotos or
like the roto brush that automatically
like does some bits like
missed my shoulder or my head parts my
hat i think
and then someone on the subreddit was
like oh mistake vfx mistake right here
and i was just like there's vfx mistakes
in every shot dude it's like oh yeah
they're like they're they're always
gonna is gonna be a mistake but it's
like
i dealt with 99 out of 100 of them and
they found the one they're like oh
mistakes in this video i got like a
thousand votes on our freaking
subreddit it doesn't it's like saying
mistaken and i mean it was it was a
pretty clear mistake i messed up i
should have gotten that and i didn't
yeah but i know but like
there's no there's no mistake there's no
perfection in anything that's been
built yeah yeah by by people like you
there's
there will always be and the builders
are usually the most critical of it
you know unless it's like like a pixar
movie you know no there's still mistakes
in this yeah there's no
i ask any of those guys who work on them
they'll tell you i'd consider
i'd consider uh a mistake
from like if the audience catches it
that's a mistake
but if the audience doesn't catch it
there's no mistakes but that's the way
that's the way i see if you show it to
another effects artist and then they
catch it isn't that the audience
catching it
yeah yeah yeah so definitely like on one
viewing in real time
so there's there will always be a
mistake
never could you never could you have a
whole show based around this
never could you make it and never could
you make a piece that
someone will watch and say there are no
mistakes in this
that is perfect well it depends on the
complexity of what it is you're looking
at
i mean i am vouching that most
pixar movies are pretty much perfect
on upon visually of on all levels
but the first time you watch something
in real time
and you don't see mistakes there's no
mistakes if you watch it again in slow
mo and you zoom in like we do on vfx
starts react
there's gonna be mistakes yeah but what
about like mistakes and like
story structure and like yeah yeah
that's valid or continuity even you know
yeah
or like you think there's no mistakes in
story structure in pixar movies
there's something i'd say that's all lid
solid
stories are pretty good but there's it's
a little bit more subjective though
story mistakes are subjective they are
agreed
continuity mistakes are not though and
even cg movies like
you know i don't care about continuity
they still have
they still have continuity issues and if
you don't care you don't care but either
way there's like
there's whole message boards and you
know i know i i think there's all kinds
of asterisk on what i said i care about
continuity to a certain extent it's like
how obvious is the
discontinuity here honestly like at the
end of the day if it takes you away from
the moment
like and away from the emotion of the
scene then it's
i think a mistake yeah but if it's if it
doesn't like you know
uh take you out of that then i don't
think okay
so what missed what mistakes did we make
not story mistakes but technical
mistakes in tactical reloads
that people oh you're going to expect
people to notice
can we pull up can i share my screen
like
the green the bandana changes colors the
bandana changes colors
it does yeah it does yeah yeah uh nico's
bandana during the
the because we had to do we or that you
guys had to shoot a bunch of like pickup
shots
yeah after the fact right yeah and one
of those was a quick zoom
onto a nico close-up where he goes
reloading
yeah and that is a green bandana whereas
uh he's usually wearing
is red one red bandanna well okay wasn't
the idea that you could just color shift
it to red
i know but we didn't catch it so [ __ ] us
so we all suck because all of our
eyeballs did not see it
yeah okay no it's like it's the plan but
then we all forget
about the thing you never know yeah no
one really cares
it was just here's a little i'm gonna
let a little cat out of the bag it's
just a kitten
so don't be too alone no but
nico's bandana
for every episode of tactical is
actually the mexican flag
it is the mexican flag yeah so that's
why it's green
and red and white in different scenes
because it gets rolled up differently
every time yeah exactly
oh that's great that's a good one that's
a good one it's amazing
because we were like yeah you need a
bandana and he's like oh
i'll take this one and i was like okay i
guess
you know like i don't know what
character motivation your character has
to wear the mexican bandana or affecting
but i think he just liked the fact that
it was like not all the same
color it's got a good look yeah but it
is also a good look
it's setting yourself up for continuity
errors though yeah
i got a bad one i got a bad one for you
guys go for it
this one's just ridiculous
and tactical three loads when they're in
the car it was all green screen
right oh yeah and you know matt you
pulled
a legendary key on those green screen uh
bits there i did a good job i had
nightmares about that key
um i lost sleep but the the close-ups of
matt were not
included oh there's two mats by the way
matt best um who played
uh the beefy tactical boy in the back
seat
those close-ups of matt that was a green
screen too dude and
they were not included and to be done as
vfx shots
and you just cut and there's just a
green screen behind them
and it's i last second pulled the pulled
the green out which i'm colorblind so
who knows it's probably still there and
yeah that's one
it's like obvious that there's not a
background in those inserts it's a it's
a
it's a beige background yeah all those
inserts it's a washed
beige background yeah uh-huh i did
notice that
i did not notice that you didn't know
okay so there you go notice i i
i noticed that i didn't notice the red
bandana
versus the color i don't know what you
noticed that's wrong with tactical three
loads
no red your turn what what what are you
doing what are you gonna you got you got
something
no it was flawless oh come on
it was perfect i don't want to say the
one
i don't want to say it is yours
what we're out and everybody right now
everybody's getting is it because it's
your mistake or is that why no it's not
no clint this is something you told me
to do and i don't want to out you on it
throw me under the bus dude no i'm not
doing it
i'm going to keep eating these chips in
the mic until you can't eat
chips into the microphone in a pot there
are some proxy files in the final video
all right we had no time look we had no
time
nico approved it he was out of town it
was all greenlit
down the whole line and i was like you
know what screw it all right
we're so close and that's how the coffee
cup ended up in that episode of
no no no not at all not even remember
or yeah yeah going with the thrones oh
man
i mean it did make it past a bunch of
eyeballs and no one noticed it that's
actually closer to the thing that matt
was talking about with the green bandana
yeah just like no one no one caught it
dude or the extra and or no the uh the
crew
member and this is america music video
you guys see that one oh yeah
no i mean i did but i don't know the
crew you're talking about that video
that i think that would be harder to
spot
then this is america at the end when
it's like like dolling out of the
warehouse
you'll see in the right corner there's a
crew member standing there with like
the earpiece and a coffee oh nice and
he's like he's
right there and it's like maybe that was
maybe that was also america though
yeah it was part of the final it was
intended
i don't know i mean donald glover like
maybe he'd pull a move like that
okay so proxy shots so these aren't in
4k
okay let me let me clarify exactly what
i mean by a proxy shot so for this whole
process
we were using because we're all working
from home we're all doing effects from
home but we got to get the files to each
other
so when we're doing final high quality
renders uh those are big
beefy files and it takes a long time to
transfer them so what we're doing to
actually like you know
uh give notes on these shots we're
rendering out half resolution actually
technically quarter resolution shots so
instead of 4k they're 1080p
and instead of being 10-bit they're
8-bit files it's the only difference
it delivers much smaller files that
upload quicker you download them quicker
all that good stuff and that's what
we're all doing for most of the shots
and the idea is that once the shot is
approved we go back and we render it at
the full quality and upload it
and we did that for the vast majority of
shots but there were a few shots
that we needed to go back and re-render
in full full quality
but we didn't
[Laughter]
we'll leave it at that actually we don't
actually have people away check this out
check this out i did you know why
because i used media encoder
oh shift control m
dude there was a large number of shots
there was probably half
half of the shots were just 1080p
no no it was less than that i don't know
there weren't many it was a small it
wasn't like two or three
it was it was several it was more than
several dude there was but there were
also a lot of shots in general don't
tell rico
to watch this podcast he won't make it
this far he will not make it this far
yeah okay the only reason why you want
to have a 10-bit file is so that it
doesn't break down under color grading
and the reason didn't break it down
enough exactly
yeah exactly so
here's another moving on here's another
tiny kitten
hey is someone's discord on or is that
just me because
my discord is off but i'm still getting
discord pings
i have yet to hear a single discord ping
yeah i got discord pings
okay then uh let me just make sure it's
christian not talking to me in the chat
of this video it's not
i'm we're not you're driving somebody
crazy why
it's all in your head my discord is
literally
closed and i'm getting discord sounds
it's on your phone maybe no it's not my
wait
no wait do you guys get it it could be
good it could be your first chord sounds
no it's not it's coming remember back in
the day when like you'd have your
headphones in and you'd get a text
message and you'd start hearing like
this
you're like oh i'm about to get a text
message bing there it is that still
happens sometimes
i hear it through the speakers sometimes
do you guys get that feeling
yeah it's because you're on android got
him
threw him under the bus got him no it's
i'm actually kind of serious because it
means you have to receive text messages
rather than just imessage
uh which is data which is blue so it's
better
like legit do you feel your your your
pocket vibrate
sometimes what you're describing is is
is a real thing though
it's a real phenomenon a lot of people
uh have said that they feel like they've
they're getting text messages when
they're
are you suffering from getting ghost
text messages
like phantom text perhaps phantom
wrestlers
vibrated in your pocket
have you ever had a discord text discord
syndrome
do you suffer from not having friends
then you're not going to have
difficulties because you won't get text
messages
okay here's another tiny kitten um
out of the bag speaking of kittens
there's one nod on your
couch in the background there clint he's
gonna make an appearance
yeah anyway okay so uh the black rifle
guys
i believe up until like a year ago
they would upload all of their youtube
videos
in 7 20.
[Laughter]
i stopped doing that in 2008 yeah
i know the thing is did you notice
no of course not no what he did is it's
so overblown
yeah nobody did it's it's compression is
the biggest thing
compression matters so much more than
resolution
that's the main reason why i prefer
watching a blu-ray a 1080p blu-ray
instead of a 4k
digital download because the compression
is better the file sizes are gonna be
way larger on your blu-ray
uh the classic example i love to use is
uh pans labyrinth in the beginning when
they're walking through the forest
you can see all these tiny little
particles floating in the air catching
sunbeams
on the streamed version of that even the
4k streamed version of it you do not see
it
well yeah compression is and i didn't
and i didn't notice this until
uh we started um
exporting we've always done this but
we started giving the exports to patron
uh users to patreon like we would give
them the high res
quality and uh
one of them was 4k and one of them was
1080. uh-huh
clinton are you chasing your cat sorry i
was really distracted by clint there for
a moment
hold on guys bear with me hold on guys
uh
so we we for i forget which video it was
but we didn't have a 4k
version and i was like oh okay well we
have to give people the 1080 version
yeah give them something at least yeah
um so we're like okay fine we'll give
them the best 1080 version we can
we have i don't know why we maybe it was
wizard cops because we don't for that
one we only had uh
i love wizard cops but anyway that's
yeah that's a fun one
i think i think because we almost lost
that whole project
and the only reason it was saved is
because i had an export of it on my
phone
oh wow oh it came down to that huh yeah
i remember this was that wizard cops
yeah
that was wizard cops dang
like your little like sim card on your
phone yeah not the sim card the sd card
the sd card
that was the toy story moment there you
know that happened with the film toy
story
pixar blunders it was the second one
right there's the second one
yeah basically this the thing is like uh
they were
it was kind of like a work from home
situation and they had like
all of the the data from um pretty much
like i guess all the character models
and everything that was
like rigged and animated was on one like
computer
and uh their server crashed or sorry
their their whole one of their servers
crashed and it just wiped out the whole
like studio's
freaking uh data right oh my god and so
this
this one work from home computer ended
up being the only
source of the entire movie of toy story
2.
right oh my god the movie the project
files the project
yeah the project all the assets
everything in that movie was on this one
computer
and so i don't i can't imagine being the
freaking pa or whoever
to drive anything back to the studio in
an armored truck
on lord of the rings i forget which one
i think it was the second one uh
uh they were transferring files from new
zealand to i think
london and at one point they had some
really
like important files on an ipod that's
how they were transferring these files
we're on an
ipod not a portable hard drive those
weren't really a thing but an ipod was
and it had a lot a lot of space and they
were literally just loading these ipods
with uh like literally like the footage
and effect
shots from the actual lord of the rings
movie that made
it to the final film they're flying them
commercially
in a dude's pocket to london isn't that
because uh
peter i was like peter jackson's wi-fi
was so bad that they had to deliver the
footage through the ipods
i think it was something like that
mcdonald's wi-fi
i mean this is you know this is 20 years
ago internet wasn't really that good
that's
even choppier down under
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so anyway back to compression for a
second um
i got something to add on that when
you're done okay also
is it about rocket jump is it about bghs
no it's about compression
the first season of eghs only exists on
the internet by the way
oh yes i have heard that
no i don't know anything about that you
don't know anything about this
no i don't know how do i know about this
video game high school season one
ceased to exist it doesn't exist
anywhere the only place that exists
is on youtube it exists in a 1080 export
on youtube
in that compression which is tragic
oh man yeah i mean didn't didn't uh i
mean it was on netflix for some time
yes how do you think they got it there
they downloaded it from youtube
they rip it up youtube i don't think
this is public knowledge by the way we
may have just outed them
no that we've talked about this bigger
channels than this yeah
okay so okay they've already been outed
yeah wait so that's confirmed though
that yeah yeah they downloaded from
youtube and sent yeah next time we have
freddie
we'll have to tell the whole story no
that that part clint i made up but
i mean i think the the actual 1080p file
is somewhere on a hard drive but like
basically
everything else is gone basically yeah
there was there was
uh i forget who had it it was like ben
one of the editors
had it and and freddie and him were
working on something
maybe it was benji and he was in and and
freddie gave him the drive and he was
like look here this is the one
and i don't mean to pin this all on
freddy i i may be getting some of the
details wrong here so pardon me but this
is the way that it was retold to me
so freddie like gave him the drive and
he was like
and it says in in like big pink letters
like fluorescent pink or something like
do not delete project vghs season one
like
and there was some miscommunication i
don't know whose fault it was or what
happened but there was something
that was scribbled out it said do delete
yeah there was some communication as to
whether or not this
particular hard drive had been actually
copied over onto another one
or another ones like several and so
there was there was a mis understanding
as to whether or not
you could delete it even though it had
all this language about it that said do
not delete
and and so freddie was under this mis
understanding and he was like look no
you can delete this i swear
dude how how like could you imagine like
getting being a pa
just like first day and just like you
have like the head guy who like you
watch all his videos
and you're and he's telling you like
yeah dude like he's he's like walking
upstairs and he tells you about all like
dude we got like our funded show
it's like so sick like we filmed
everything like we're actually about to
release
the oscars yeah the movie yeah yeah it's
like everything
like you're meeting you're meeting like
the executives and like we're so excited
to get this and then like
fred brings in the room and he's like
all right look so you can delete this i
know it says do not delete but trust me
trust me like look at me trust me you
can delete this
and you're like are you sure you're like
like no 100 and then you delete it and
you're like dude you shouldn't have
deleted that
yeah no i don't think i think it was i
don't think it was freddie's fault
either
it may have been but i i don't know um
but like i think
we'll never know yeah somewhere along
the line we'd like to ask him more
clearly about it at some point here to
get the true
the full details but that's kind of
reminds me of what we've done before
you see it does happen that's the thing
is it's like how could this happen and
i mean i'm thinking of how all the vlogs
were deleted off of the raid
multiple times never buy car michael
the original deleted sports no not the
original exports all of the project
files all the footage
basically everything oh that's except
well okay
until it's not
i mean until you need the raw footage
until yeah
no we were doing a project and we didn't
have any of the footage that we needed
for because i
started it the year before and i was
completing it the next year and we
needed
the stuff to have all my soldering and
all the stuff for the freaking
batteries and all that footage was gone
stirring up old demons right now videos
that's the video where you're making the
battery
yeah it was the boosted board thing
there was a bunch of stuff that i had
filmed for it
and it because i'd done all that stuff
at like the end of the previous year and
it was in like that
2016 and we're running out of space on
the raid and nico doesn't want to pay
for more space so
and carmichael's like all right i'm just
going to delete everything it was it
got a little overzealous with how
relevant
the old footage was yeah and
i remember that well listen we just
we just got a new server today yeah
yeah we did yeah that is true we're
finally to the point how much how much
storage do we have now total
now it's like a hundred and two hundred
terabytes space
good good yeah and then 40 was not
enough so here's the thing
here's the best part uh once we get that
to a point where we're like hey it's
getting kind of full we can move
over all of that onto tape drives and we
can create a tape drive system
which is like an even it's it's
basically like a jukebox
for data like
you store your drives and then like it
it
stores them like across all these
different drives and you can just keep
adding drives to it exponentially
and then whenever it needs something
like this this little machine
that moves around and grabs the tape and
then like puts it into
uh the player to upload it onto like a
warm drive
so you can actually access it it's crazy
and it takes it off of disks and it puts
it onto tapes
because i guess yeah these certain types
of tapes that they
are using now for it are more reliable
yeah i don't know much about the tape
drives i know spencer knows quite a bit
about him and he swears by him but yeah
i'm i'm sure somebody in the comments
would be like tape drives are the worst
thing ever how could you guys do this
you're going to ruin everything
but this is what we know so far so you
want to know why i'm never going to do a
raid
hard drive anymore because if one fails
they all fail
well i mean yeah that uh the idea of i
mean there's multiple different kinds of
rated hard drives but
uh i had one hard drive that was like it
was the same hard drive mirrored with
another one but it was at the raid level
and it's this one right here so i my
computer died i can't use it at all
anymore so my work computer that i have
here at home is my only computer
and so i needed some files off of this
computer so all right here's my hard
drive
except my little hard drive reader here
which i i plug into this thing you know
and that's how i got my other hard drive
to work you need
two yep you need two
i can't read this one without this one
also plugged in at the exact same time
yeah oh yeah yep that's right
for you you got to unraid those bad boys
divorce
now it's like i'm sure i can figure it
out i'm sure there's some sort of
solution to get that to work and plug
into my computer
but fortunately the critical files i
needed weren't on those drives so
just not dealing with it i just it just
sucks i'm like ugh does this mean
effectively that these are dead drives
because i'm never going to look at them
again
if i'm being honest with myself yeah
probably i'll take him i'll take him so
anyways so
tactical to wrap this up to wrap this up
about the 1080
compression thing oh yeah i want to add
on that okay
i sent out the patreon hi-res
export the uncompressed version but it
was still 1080.
and i and i looked at it and the quality
was incredible compared to what was on
youtube
and yet it was the same file
and i was like nico what's going on here
why is the 1080 file that's on the
monitor
look 100 times better than the 1080 file
that's on youtube
and he goes oh that's just compression
and i go what
so you mean this whole time this whole
time
4k is just been like a it's like a myth
it's like yeah 4k yeah yes okay it is
better
but like it's not that much
better it isn't when you're talking
about an uncompressed file
like when you have like a good quality
4k
file and you're viewing it on a 4k
display yes you can definitely notice
the difference but
that crispiness like it is noticeable i
can very easily see it
but at the same time it's not something
that i'll typically notice
uh i don't know i i so if you're
watching a crisp 1080 file
on a 1080 monitor that is going to look
at low compression it's going to look
great
it's going to look great and a 4k is
only going to look better but in terms
of like
what people's expectations are for what
create what equates to quality it's like
by far more compression has to do with
it than anything else
so what i do sometimes and i don't do
this all the time because i don't care
enough
but what i have done a few times before
for like my little science videos
is that i i do all of it in 1080p right
i shoot on a freaking canon 80d for
these shots as opposed to the red camera
and all my effects files are
8-bit 1080p like i don't care and i
finished the whole thing
but then i export the video upscaled to
4k
so i'm literally just premiere
exporting sometimes i'll export it at
1080p then i'll bring it into a new
export
size it up and then export that natively
i haven't figured out which one is
better as opposed to just natively doing
it within premiere reactions you can add
that sharpen up
after the like a little unsharp look
just a little sure yeah uh
but the reason why i do that is because
on youtube when you upload a 4k
file you unlock a higher bit rate
across the board and so your file will
end up looking better if it's in a 4k
format even though this has been
semi-confirmed
and it's sometimes it stuff's always
changing
uh you know behind the scenes in
hey gizmo i'm not going to export at
that bitrate your
gosh dang platform's just going to take
a dump all over it anyway
well but like what i'm saying we're
going home jimmy if you have a 1080p
file you export it at 4k and you upload
it in 4k it will look better than it
does at 1080 because it has
because 4k has to have like
way higher bitrate because if you have
the same bit rate for a 1080p
file than a 4k file it's like the 4k
file
each pixel will have a quarter of the uh
the bits
for each pixel to go through and so
anyway that's what i'm saying it's like
yeah it's it's it's upload like youtube
thinks it's a 4k file
and and it looks good it looks really
good and it looks a little bit better
than if it was just a 1080p file
did anyone notice no one noticed that
about ren's videos
in fact i brought it up on twitter at
some point a couple weeks ago and
maybe longer i don't remember and and
there were a few people who were really
salty about it
like i only want pure absolute
4k footage when i want to look at 4k and
you're
using how dare you dilute my pool of
4k videos then go on to corridor
digital.com
get yourself a monthly subscription okay
and then watch our 4k videos that are
uploaded in 4k
onto our website on your 4k
monitor and that's going to be one of
the best viewing experiences
you're going to ever have another thing
about youtube though is that they
always still have the original file you
uploaded and they are constantly making
uh innovations in compression and they
will actually re-export your
original file to all the different
because that's what they have to do for
every time you upload a video you know
how you click the little bar and you
have like all these different resolution
options
those are different videos that youtube
automatically generates
every time you upload a video oh yeah
the 1440 the 1440p
1080 720 480 uh potato like
there are all separate videos that
youtube generally knows
and so it has that that original file
behind the scenes no one has access to
it
so several years ago i want to say like
seven maybe
uh they switched their codec system i
want to say it was like vp9
something around the time it was a big
big overhaul in how youtube adjusted
stuff
and they they back they went to their
backlog of all these 4k videos and they
re-exported them in this new
codec that made them all instantly
better
no what they do on the back end over
there is nothing short of
of a goddamn miracle like having having
just
gone through some of this stuff on the
website on our own website
and then seeing like oh we have to scott
needs to make an encoder
that encodes this file that we give him
into
five different resolutions and then it
needs to play
in real time as if you know
as if it's all one and you don't notice
and it's just like you're
just watching it wizardry yeah and then
and then also having the ability on your
back end to like
go in remember when they just updated
every
uh thumbnail from four three to sixteen
nine because he used to be able to
upload four or three thumbnails way back
in the day on youtube
and then they went in and they put out
an update that just like
updated all of them to 16 9
to make it format with the rest of what
they were doing on the site yeah
they've done stuff like remember time
that that had to have happened
yeah i don't specifically remember did
it just crop the four three
thumbnails uh yeah um it did
um and you know most of that stuff you
don't see today because it's all really
old stuff on the site
but uh they've done stuff like that time
and again where they'll just
go and they'll do these massive updates
and
nobody and people will just be like oh
hey this is a funny video
you know no one's noticed no no one
notices and then you know every now and
then
like something will glitch and you know
like for example i think it was two
years ago was the last time the site
went down
and it went down for like 30 minutes and
it was
it was like world news yeah you know
this is amazing what happens behind the
scenes on a platform that large it's
unbelievable
so anyway so tactical three loads right
yeah so anyway
speaking of which guys if you haven't
seen it yet please go on and check out
tactical reloads it's on the corridor
youtube channel you know where to find
it come on
i really liked it i thought it was
really good and
it was a lot of fun it's done been
performing great
uh which has been awesome i noticed that
i was like all right hey
yeah sometimes corridor videos don't do
very well and it's like well
oh well yeah uh so it's always
reassuring to see that that that um you
know
that concepts like that still have legs
and
and can live in today's today's
cutting-edge world today's
short short attention spans and all that
sort of thing
know that people are still into the
reloads and the storylines and all that
stuff
uh cool so anyway yeah um huge thanks to
you guys for
making it all happen and uh on to the
next one
on to that next one let's do it yeah
whatever
birthday today is it yeah
happy birthday freddy happy birthday
birthday
happy birthday uncle freddie wow uh
[Laughter]
make a comment yeah make a comment all
right guys
good times great night yeah you too
peace out guys
see you later later